>> CHERRY: All right. Hi, everyone. Thank
you for coming to another Google Authors@Google
event. I'm very excited to co-host this event
with Jessie and the team, and introduce all
of you to our featured author, Carole Meyers.
She's an award-winning travel writer and a
native San Franciscan like a lot of you here.
Carole holds a B.A. degree in anthropology
from San Francisco State University and an
elementary teaching credential from Fresno
State College. She's the author of 19 books.
She is editor of 6 books, and the mother two
children--with whom she's been through the
road wars and in the travel trenches first
hand. And you can read a little bit about
that through her books. Her books include
"Weekend Adventures in San Francisco and Northern
California," which we'll talk about today.
She's also written "Miles of Smiles: 101 Great
Card Games and Activities." She is the editor
of "Dream Sleeps: Castles and Palaces Hotels
of Europe," and she is a founding publisher
of Carousel Press. An active freelancer, her
articles have appeared in variety of publications
including "Parenting," "Family Fun," "Family
Circles," "Sunset," and numerous other magazines
as well as travel sections of many newspapers.
She has written a column for several publications
including "The San Jose Mercury News," "Expedia.com,"
and she's been a featured guest on the "Today's
Show," "CNN," and "Bay Area Backroads." A
fun fact about Carole--I know how Googlers
love fun facts--is that in a different career
path, she was actually an extra on Mick Jagger's
"Vision of Paradise" video, and you can ask
her about that during Q&A. Ms. Meyers is a
member of the Society of American Travel Writer
and resides in Berkeley, California. So, let's
all welcome Carole Meyers to Google. Thank
you.
>> MEYERS: Thank you. That was very nice.
That was a very nice introduction. Thank you.
Okay. Well, we're going to talk about "Weekend
Adventures" today, and I'll just--I'm going
to give you just a little brief introduction
to how the book is arranged. Can you hear
me okay in the back there? Okay? All right,
one of the--one of the things that I've done
with this book that makes it a little different
than some books is that it is arranged so
that it's really easy to find things, and
especially like, for instance, say you're
on the road and you decide to change your
plans and you want to stop in, say you're
in San Mateo or something. And you want to
get off the road and go to lunch. You can
easily find it in the book, something in San
Mateo that--to give you a starting point.
The book is arranged so that it fits in a
glove compartment, it's supposed to fit. And
it is arranged so it's coast up, coast north,
coast south, 101 north, 101 south, et cetera;
Gold Rush Country, Lake Tahoe. It's arranged
in sections like that. And there are introductory
maps that sort of positioned you where you
are. It's always good to have a backup street
map definitely wherever you're going. I forget
that basic fact sometimes and I--you know,
I regret it usually. So, always try to get
those maps with you before you leave. Okay,
so this is the book. And now, you know what,
Cherry? I think I need you just to show me
which key here I'm going to use to go--to
move forward. Is it this one right here? That's
going to move me...
>> CHERRY: No.
>> MEYERS: This one.
>> CHERRY: There you go.
>> MEYERS: That's what I want. Okay. Thank
you. Okay, so we've already talked a bit about
my background. And at my website, and Jessie
will send you an email later with website
and blog addresses, but you can write them
down too, if you want to. But I do have--I
do have travel articles posted at my website.
And this is the caroletmeyers.com website.
I have about three or four websites, so I'll
to differentiate them for you. But if you're
just sort of wanting to browse and get some
ideas for some good places to go and things
to do, I do maintain a listing of travel articles
that I've written that I think that are particularly
informative at the website. And I also do
write fairly regularly right now for the "Chronicle:
Travel Section" for these five places that
they're doing each Sunday. And so, you might
see an article in there that you'll find of
use also. Okay, and also regarding the "Weekend
Adventure" structure of the book. It also--this
is something I want you know since you're
all going to have a copy of the book, you
want to know this, I include--I'm selective
about including special and a lot of historical
places in the book. So they--to get into my
book, they first have to be vetted by me.
I have been to almost every place. Occasionally,
I will go on somebody's word that I trust
that it's worth putting in, but I like to
see something first-hand. And this book has
grown from the first edition to the ninth
edition. That's why it's gotten bigger because
I've visited more places. But they have to--they
have to be vetted by me first, and then they--I
also like them to be special in some way or
else why bother. Occasionally special is a
cheap sleep where you can actually get a bargain.
That's harder to get nowadays. It used to
be that I had a section called "Cheap Sleeps".
And I think the criteria was $50 or less for
two people for a night. Well, that, you know,
there's next to nothing anymore like that
except the hostels. And those are actually--anybody
can go to the hostels too, and they're a bargain.
Also, I have an annual events index in the
back that is really nice when you're just
kind of uninspired about what you want to
do or maybe you've got a--maybe you want to
take a vacation right now and you'd like to
center it around an annual event. It's according
to each month and you can go into the back
and you can look at the annual events and
see what's happening and then go to that section
and set up your trip. Okay. And annual events
are a fun thing to center your travel around.
I have four blogs, I have the Weekend Adventures
Update blog. All at blogspot, by the way,
which I thought you might appreciate that.
The Weekend Adventures Update is coordinated
with the book. I just started that blog when
this book was published. And what it does
is like when I visit a new restaurant or take
a new weekend trip or find out something has
changed significantly, I will put it into
the blog and coordinate it with the book so
that you can say, "Go to the blog and you
can look up," say, "Mendocino," and you can
just click there and see what I've written
about Mendocino, which currently is nothing.
No updates to Mendocino. But you could do
that and check before you go just to see what's
happening. I also have the Travels With Carole
blogspot, which is the world. And I do travel
a lot to other places besides Northern California
so. And the one I really want to tell you
about is this Webcam Traveler which is also
a website. And that is a website that has
a Google Map on it. And it uses the pins.
And every week, I add a new pin and it's all
about webcams that are--that are focused on
either a site, for instance, the Pyramids
or Time Square in New York, which is one of
my favorite ones, or an animal, like the snow
monkeys in Japan, which I also love and which
I think was the very first one that we posted.
And so--and then so it makes it really easy
to waste a minute or two just going to the
website and click, click, click, click and
see what your favorite places and animals
are up to. And I Twitter too. All right, you
guys don't need to see this. I have some of
these blogs in here because I do talk to a
lot of people that don't even know what a
blog is. So we'll skip through this. You know
how they're set up. This is how the Webcam
Traveler website looks. These are the—well,
this is the other book that I wrote that was
already mentioned to you, and the two other
books that were mentioned that I've edited.
"Camping Europe", I'm not sure if we mentioned
that one, but that's about taking camping
trips in Europe. It's a great book written
by another person who lives in Half Moon Bay
who just does a great job on finding every
little itty bitty bit of information you would
want to camp your way through Europe. You
can go to pretty much any of those websites
or blogs and find some way to sign up for
the free e-letter. And you can also, of course,
sign up for the blogs with FeedBurner, individually.
But I do send out an e-letter that goes out
to, maybe, I get two at about once a month
or so. And it will just sort of nudge you
to tell you that there's new stuff at this
blog and there's new stuff at that website.
It's very short and sweet. Let's see. Everybody
is going to be getting a book today, so that's--we'll
skip that one. And do please make comments
or ask questions as we go. Some of you may
have been to some of these places and have
something to add, that's good. And now, let's
just sit back and enjoy the ride, and I'm
going to give you some slides. We're going
to start with Clear Lake. How many of you
have been to Clear Lake? Okay. Clear Lake
is up Highway 101, a couple of hours north
of here, and it tends to--it tends to be a
place for the-—it's--Sacramento is the city
that feeds in to Clear Lake. A lot of people
from there tend to go to Clear Lake because
it's so close. But it's close for us too.
And you could easily do it as a day trip.
And all of these trips, really, you can do
as a day trip. But all the information's there
for you to turn it into an overnight also,
which is, of course, I think, more fun to
spend a little more time. One of the newsy
things up at Clear Lake is it used to be a
place that it was known for its orchards.
And it grows—-well, they still grow pears
there and apples and--they're known for their
pears though. And, but they're slowly taking
those out and replacing them with grapes.
And I was surprised to see, on my recent trip
there, yes, I visited here last year, about
this time, that they have several nice wineries
there now. I was surprised by that. And this
one in particular is like a destination winery.
And you can see that beautiful lavender. It's--the
lavender fields are in bloom now. This is
the time of year. It was stunning, and the
fragrance, and it just—-this winery is on
the lake. And I think that the fact was it's
the only winery on the lake in the country.
You can see the lake there, and you can see
more of that lavender. And it's a great spot
to visit. But one of the things I really enjoyed
was the tour that they had which took you
around to see how they do their organic gardening
with their--with their vineyards. And a lot
of wineries are switching over to doing this
type of growing grapes instead of using pesticides
and everything. But this winery had a very
unique thing to see and that was--they used
chickens to keep things going in there. They
let the chickens out in the morning. And they
have them in this kind of like a wooden trailer,
like a gypsy trailer, like you've probably
seen, you know. We've seen pictures of that?
I went too far there. And they let them out
in the morning and they go--the chickens run
around and they eat and they poop and they
just have a grand day among the vineyards.
And then at night, they go back into their
coop and they--it's on wheels, so they move
it during the night. And then in the morning,
the chickens are in a new place. And it's
amazing, the kind of wines they're producing
with that--that simple change. When you go
to these--a lot of these wineries now, they
have some really great tours. This is another
change that I've noticed in the last four
or five years. The wineries have always had
tourists. And a long time ago, they used to
be basically free. You know, any winery you
went to, it would be free. And then they,
some of them started charging a bit for it,
sort of like the tasting. And now, there's
this other class of tours that are developing
in a lot of the wineries and they're a special
occasion kind of tours. Like, you can go and
you can--they cost quite a bit. They can be
50 bucks and more sometimes. But they often
will include perhaps, conversation with the
winemaker, perhaps lunch will be included
or perhaps--who knows what. There's all kinds
of angles on it. This winery, the Langtry
Estate, is--I think in Middletown is the place
it's located which is the south end of the
lake. And on--you can actually continue on
that route to Calistoga. And we did this last
year. We turned that Clear Lake visit into
finishing up in Calistoga in coming home.
It was quite, a quite nice little road trip.
But the Langtry Estate did--has that kind
of tour where they take you up into the--into
their--into a specific vineyard and they pour
wine for you and they include lunch. And what
was unique here is that the wine that this
gentleman is pouring is made from the grapes
that are in that very vineyard that you're
sitting in having your lunch, which is just
kind of nice. It makes everything taste better
and it's just--it's a fun thing. And this
particular winery owns all the property around
it, as far as you can see. And where they
do this picnic is up on a hill there where
you can really see a beautiful view. So that's
an example of one of the tours. And of course,
you can go to these wineries without taking
the tour and just do tasting. And some of
the wineries will—-you know, some of them
that actually charge the taste. There are
a few wineries nowadays that don't charge.
I hope that stays that way for a while. But
before you leave on a trip, where you know
you're going to go wine tasting, check out
the website of the winery and a lot of times
you'll find a coupon there for a free tasting,
or a two for one, or something. So, it's a
good thing to check out and take advantage
of. Also at the Clear Lake, an annual event
that they have, and I believe this one happens
in the spring, it's the Heron Festival, and
a lot of unusual birds are seen there at that
time. And one of the nice things about going
to an annual event is that they will often
have special things that you can do during
that event that you can't do at any other
time. And that's like at Clear Lake, you're
taking this Pontoon Boat Tours, they—-that's
unique and very popular and it sells out fast.
So if there's something like this that interests
you, you want to get on it and make sure you
get those tickets ahead of time and plan.
Also this particular event has a Wildflower
Brunch which is a fundraiser and also very
popular. Clear Lake State Park, also up there.
Now, the state parks, let's hope they stay
open. But usually, you'll just have to pay
to park and sometimes you can get away with
not even paying to park. You can park your
car outside the premises and walk in and usually
there's no fee then. But sometimes definitely
the convenience is worth it. And the state
parks, I mean, almost all of them are worth
taking a visit to. This is one is just really
beautiful and right on the lake. Also, this
is something new at the Clear Lake. Clear
Lake has been—-it's kind of a step into
the past. It hasn't quite caught up with what's
going on in the rest of the--well, not in
the rest of the world, but let say in San
Francisco. It isn't into full-scale fancy
hotels and expensive everything, of which
a lot of the tourism areas are moving that
direction. There is no Ritz-Carlton here.
And somebody said to me, I think it was on
this trip, that they hope that they were long
gone by the time Ritz-Carlton decides to move
in here. So what you do find is a lot of motels
that date from the '30s and '40s and way back,
a lot of little log cabin-type things. Some
of them very comfortable and pleasant, and
some of them, you know, really falling down.
And in some of those places you can just sort
of waltz in at the last minute and get yourself
a room. This--usually there is room in that,
in Clear Lake. There's several casinos up
there now. But the Tallman Hotel, which is
up at the North Lake, yeah, somebody just
loved that hotel and renovated it. And it's
a beautiful old hotel that I believe dates
from the 1840s. I think it was around during
the Gold Rush. And high ceilings, beautiful
structure to it, and I think they have about
maybe eight rooms in the main hotel, and they're
all beautifully updated. And one of the things
I love the best about this place was they
have the--they have antique plumbing, and
that works. But what's great is its beautiful
antique plumbing. It's the kind, you know,
with tubes that go here and there, and all
kind--I mean, it's just a-—it's a piece
of art. And the town has a store there where
you can actually purchase the antique plumbing.
I guess they have a specialty shop. So if
you're remodeling, it's something you might
want to check out. And they also had--they
had brought in a San Francisco decorator and
spiffed it up. It's beautiful. The colors
of the fabrics and just the way it's done.
And I was thinking to myself at first when
I saw that, I thought, "Hmm, well, you know
now, may-—did they need to bring in a San
Francisco decorator." But then--then I was
thinking, "Well you know, I bet in the old
days, in the Gold Rush days, that's what they
did. They probably brought in a San Francisco
decorator to make this an attractive place
to people in those days too." But it's a little
unlike most of Clear Lake, it's just really
quite nice, very tasteful. And they have--they
have--any of the fabrics or the paint colors
or things like that that you fall in love
with, you can actually find out what they
are at the desk. They maintain a book that
tells you this. And I like--I like the color
of those chairs. So I was able to get that
paint color. And that's wonderful any of you
that are working on your houses or apartments,
you know that that can be a real godsend to
be able to get the exact color you want. They
also have next door a salon that's part of
the property. This is a fabulous place to
have a dinner outdoors or a lunch outdoors
in the summer. It's just absolutely beautiful.
There's no people in this shot but you can
see how pretty the colors are and everything,
it's well-priced. A lot of people, local people
go there to celebrate special occasions. And
one other thing about this property worth
mentioning is that they also have another
set of rooms that are in a separate building
that was built new and they have like Japanese
soaking tubs. Each room has its own private
soaking tub outside on its own private little
patio, which is unusual out there in the open
air. So, you have your choice of several kinds
of room in this particular place. All right,
Coast South; now, a lot of the places I'm
mentioning today are pretty decent bargains
for what you're getting for price wise. The
book has--as I think I mentioned a range.
You know, there's the fancy resorts that you
do want to know about too. And then there's
a lot in between and then there's some of
those cheap sleeps as well. We have a cup
of cheap sleeps here. In Pacifica which is
so close. You know, you can get there in less
than an hour on a good day. And you could
easily make that a day trip too. But the best
western lighthouse in there is worth considering
spending the night, and I have found that
a lot of best westerns tend to be interesting
hotels. They're not cookie-cutter hotels.
They are all individual and often in good
locations, interesting locations. This one
is right on the ocean and its in the Rockaway
Beach area, which is tiny little turn to the
right as you're going down Highway 1, you
just turn off on Rockaway Beach and it's--you
know, that's it, two blocks and you're to
the beach. And there's nothing much there,
a few shops of coffee house and, you know,
and a couple of motels in this beautiful beach.
This is the room that's in that Lighthouse
Inn. And right on the ocean, you could, you
know, you can hear the waves pounding outside
your window. It's just amazing. And pretty
much any of the rooms in that particular lodging,
that's the case. They all--even the cheapest
ones, you can hear the ocean. You don't have
this same view in all of them but you have
a very good access to the sound of the waves.
Okay. And right across the street, Sea Breeze
Motel. Now, this is an old motel. This is--I
think it was built in the 30's. And it's still
here. And its nothing--you know real special
design wise. It looks like when it was built.
But look at that view. And that's from all
the rooms. It's one of these little strip
motels, you know, that every room looks out
the same way. And they have a little restaurant
that's attached to it that you can have, you
know, lunch or dinner. I think they even serve
breakfast. And I wanted to mention to it that
Lighthouse Inn, the one that's across the
street from this, they have a fabulous little
Italian restaurant upstairs that is--has the
same view as that lodging. And it's really
good. I was real--I even thought the food
was delicious there, a very romantic place.
Okay. And then just a little further down,
Pacific Grove, which is the cousin to Monterey
and Carmel. Pacific Grove is a kind of--it's
quieter and it's less touristy than Carmel
or Monterey, but well-worth visiting. And
if you go at the right time of year, you're
going to see the ice plant in bloom. And I
think the right time is March. Again, these
details I do have in the book that my memory
requires me to say. I'd like to look it up
to be sure, but I think it's March. And it
can be more stunning than what you're seeing
in this picture, this is not the full bloom.
Now, they also have a little lighthouse there.
And we have a lot of lighthouses in Northern
California, and they're all in the book. And
I love lighthouses. In this particular one,
I had never been inside until just last Christmas
when I was here in the area, and I happened
to hit the right time when it was open. And
it's just a tiny little place, but it has
a couple of rooms that you can go into and
see some furnishings and things like that
and just--it's kind of nice to go inside and
see what's there. Plus, it's just a beautiful
setting. And notice also, this lady is riding
a bike. It's a good town to ride a bike in
because they have wide roads, not heavy traffic.
The bicyclist can get over to the side and
not worry that somebody is going to run him
down. It's really a nice place to rent a bike
or bring your bike. Have any of you stated
Asilomar? It's a very popular place with retreats
and that kind of thing, a lot of family reunions
go on there. It's rented by groups a lot.
But when it--and it's on--it's a state park
now, the area around it. Maybe the whole thing
is a state park, I'm not positive about that.
But when they don't rent or when they don't
have all the rooms full with a meeting or
whatever about a month out, they will start
renting the rooms to the general public. So,
you can--you know, if you're interested, they
have about--I think they have about 12 different
buildings, maybe more. And several of them
were designed by Julia Morgan who used to
go--she was--she used to go to camp here way
back. And so, it's quite an array of buildings.
Some of them have beautiful views. A lot of
them don't have views, but they have some
other aesthetic nice city. Now, I think this
was a Julia Morgan. Anyway, you can reserve
a lodging there. And then you can--they also
have a dining room, and the dining room is
like a cafeteria style, so they have a set
menu everyday with the few choices on main
entrees. I think they accommodate vegetarians.
And they have something else just incase,
you know, something doesn't work for somebody,
but you can call and find out what the menu
is that day. And anybody, whether you're staying
there or not, you can go there for a meal,
and they're very well-priced. And the reason
you might want to do that is because the dinning
room has a gorgeous view of the dunes. It's
set in the dunes in a beach beyond. And it's
kind of nice to go there and maybe have breakfast
and then set out for the day and take a walk
around there. And you can go--you can take
a walk with a ranger. They have Ranger-Led
Tours, and this ranger was particularly jolly
and nice. And you get to, you know, you'll
get to see a lot of the buildings that way,
so it's a good idea. And I don't have a picture
there of the terrain around there, but it's
beautiful. And they have boardwalks to go
right through the dunes and down to the beach,
and so, it's just kind of--it's a kind of
place where you just would hangout and be
compressed. And then, if you go into town,
the have quite a few nice little restaurants,
it's not a real fancy town as I mentioned,
but they have--this is my favorite one. It's
just a little café and it has a good food
and it's cute and they have a nice little
garden shop down underneath the main part
of that house. Also, this town is known for
its monarch butterflies, you've probably heard
about that, and they have an annual parade
everyday. I think this one is in October.
And the little kids in the town will dress
up like butterflies and march down the street.
And the word is that it's never been rained
on, which is kind of hard to believe that
they maintained that that's the truth, and
I have to take in what their word for it.
They said, "It never been rained on." And
you can see the butterflies. They have a specific
grove that the butterflies like to come back
to. And--so you'll see a lot of them at the
right time a year there. But even at the wrong
time of year, usually there's a few strugglers
around. And in Pacific Grove, it is a crime
to molest a butterfly. You do not want to
bother those butterflies. You don't want to
try to get one on your finger or, you know,
just leave them alone. I think its 500 bucks
now, it might be more. They want those butterflies
left alone and--so they--I've never seen anybody
get arrested but, you know, they have other
people will tell people, and then they leave
them alone. Okay, Coast North. Of course,
the Coast North, there's just endless places
to go, wonderful things to do all along the
coast. But this is the one that I really enjoyed
a few years ago, I visited this one in Mill
Valley, it's actually on the coast part of
Mill Valley, the Mountain Home Inn. A lot
of people wined up here before or after a
hike because they have a trail ahead across
the street from this place that a lot of people
take advantage of trailheads, I should say.
And this is a shot of breakfast on their deck,
which is included with the stay there, but
you can also go--anybody can dine at this
hotel as well whether you're staying there
or not. And it's beautifully set, so that
there's trees, you know, just everywhere off
of your room deck to beautiful view. And the
Matt Davis Trail--there is a place--I don't
think it's a trailhead, I think that trail
starts down below somewhere, but you can catch
the trail there and go on up to the West Point
Inn. And the West Point Inn is--was built
a long time ago. It's sort of like a lodge
that you would find in a national park or
something. I mean a small--smaller than what
we would see at Yosemite or something. But
that type of thing, an old structure and--that
you can spend the night there. But to spend
the night there, you--it's complicated. You
need to check ahead and make sure that they
are actually taking people that night. I don't
know if they take reservations, they might.
It's inexpensive, but you have to bring your
own sleeping bag and, you know, all your--everything.
And I think even your own food, you know.
But I think they have a place that you can
cook at. So this is something to look into
if you like to do that type of thing. It's
a very nice spot to consider. I had thought
that we would be able to get, like, a snack
when we got up to the West Point Inn because
I had never been before, this was my first
visit. And so, I was expecting, you know,
some refreshment, and we got there and it
was closed. And I found out that even on a
good day, you'd be lucky to get a glass of
lemonade. You know, they don't really--it's
not really a restaurant or anything, it's
just kind of they do a little thing. I think
it's for the benefit charity as far as the
drinks and snacks. So, check ahead of time
if you go there and don't have that happen
to you. Also, of course, you're close to Muir
Woods. And any of you that have not been to
Muir Woods, you want to visit that at some
point, it's a great place to take out-of-town
visitors who--especially, if they've never
seen a redwood tree because there is lots
of redwood trees there. They're not as big
as what you see up in Eureka, but they're
grand and out-of-towners are impressed. So,
keep that in mind next time you're in that
situation, a wonderful place to go. Also,
keep in mind--I'm almost positive, they don't
allow picnicking. I think they have a little
café that you can get a little snack, and
at least they did last time I check. And so,
bear that in mind. Also in this area--and
we've just missed it, but if any of you been
to the Audubon Canyon Ranch, you know what
I'm talking about, it's--from mid-March to
mid-July, the Egrets and the Herons, they
come here and they nests and they lay their
eggs, they--you know, the baby start hatching.
It is a rookery. And you--until you go there
and actually see it, you won't quite know
what a rookery can be like. But it's noisy
and there's feathers all over the place, and
it's just amazing to see, especially, when
those eggs are hatching, when the babies are
there. And they have--it's designed, it's
near Stinson beach. It's designed so that
you take a little hike. I mean, more like
a stroll, but a little bit of a hike, up above
where the trees are so that you're almost
eye-level with the nests. And you can look
out and just observe all the activity and
noise, its' fabulous. And this is a place
you can bring a picnic along. And they also
have there, down below, a bird hide, which
is a structure that you can go into and the
birds can't tell you're there, you know, very
quiet. But the way they designed the building,
the birds really don't know you're there and
they can't see you. And so, you really get
to observe a lot of interesting birds outside.
And they have a little museum and their barn
there too. But keep that in mind, I'm pretty
sure it's close. I don't think you can go
this weekend, but you might be able to check
on the Internet and see if they're open and
put it on your calendar for next year. Well
worth it. Wonderful drive just to go up Stinson
Beach in that area and do this and have dinner
somewhere and come home, great. And Osmosis,
which is nearby in Freestone, the town of
Freestone. This is a unique place. It's--they
do this cedar bath. And I put down what's
in it because it's kind of interesting. It's
an enzyme bath. It's a Japanese style bath.
There's nowhere else in the US that has this.
And it's sort of like a dry-mud bath, that's
how I describe it. If you've had a mud bath
that's--with all this fiber and stuff that
is wet and it gets very hot. This is dry and
it gets very hot. And the way it works is
they dig out a spot in the cedar fiber there
and you get in, and they cover you up and
these plant enzymes are decomposing. And they
produce heat when they're doing this. And
it's just an amazing thing in about 20 minutes,
you went out of there and they have this--an
attendant that will bring a nice wash--cold-wet
washcloth and put it on your forehead for
you, it feels really good, bring you something
to sip. And you stay in as long as you can
stand it, and then you get out, and then you
get washed off. And if you're smart, you will
have made a reservation for a massage, and
you can have that out in one of their pavilions
that they have that are open air, or they
basically are kind of like a little playhouse,
it's what they look like. And the window is
open to the air. And when I did this, something
fell on the tin roof in just about--I jumped--just
about jumped out of my skin, it was so loud,
and all it was, was some little twig off the
tree or something. But a very interesting
wonderful massage that they do there too,
real unique. And Freestone also is known--it's
like a little tinny tiny town that's known
for a very good bakery. And I think I've heard
that they have a winery there now that I'd
like to check out. So--but that's about it.
I don't think they even have any place to
stay, but I'm going to find out. Also, in
this area, if you like oysters, the Hog Island
Oyster Company is pretty famous. And you can
walk in there and just rent a bucket and get
a bunch of oysters there, and they will give
you the--they will give you the knife and
everything that you need to open them up and
have a picnic on the spot. And if you bring
your other things along with you, you can
have a very expensive picnic. I don't know
if they--I don't think they have all the accoutrements,
just for the oysters, but very nice, right
on the beach. Do we have time to go further?
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> MEYERS: Okay. But you let me know when
you want me to stop. Maybe we can at least
finish Crescent City. Crescent City, way up
north by the Oregon border. A lot of people
skipped Crescent City, they never get up there.
They get to Eureka and they might get a little
further, but they completely bypass Crescent
City. And I didn't put it into the book until
just this new at ninth edition because I hadn't
had a chance to really, you know, look at
the town. And I've always like it, though.
It's a great place to stay. It's very quiet.
It's another one of those places that hasn't
caught up yet. They don't have the fancy hotels
and things, just simple motels, good prices,
and it's on the way to Oregon. You can stop
there for the night and then keep on going
on up into Oregon--on the Oregon Coast, which
is also beautiful, or you can turn around
and come back. But it's just a great little
city and nice to know about, and they have
some unique things there. They have this lighthouse,
the Battery Point Lighthouse which--is another
cute little lighthouse. And you can only visit
it when the tide's out. When the tide's in,
it becomes an island. And you can't go up
there. And so they have tours, and I believe
everything is free in this. They have tours
on specific days when the tide is going to
be out. And what you do is you park your car
in a lot that they've got, and then you walk
across--it's almost like going to visit a
castle. And when we went, you know, we saw
a poor little stranded star fish and things
like that. They were waiting for that tide
to come back in. And you can go up there and
you could--if you bring along a picnic, this
is another place you can picnic. And they
have a light keeper who actually lives in
this lighthouse, and that's a group of kids
from a school that we're visiting the same
day. And I thought, "Oh," you know, when we
were there and they came along, I thought
this is going to be--this is going to be difficult.
It turns out those kids added so much fun
to the experience because they were--they
got so excited. They were so excited about
being there. So, I wound up having more fun
because they were there. But somehow, we all
squeezed in there and we went up to the top
too, that was interesting, on a ladder. And
this is the light keeper, and he was a jolly
guy and he was telling us the way he got his
job was that he was taking a tour, one day
he came to visit. And the light keeper before
him was mentioning that he was quitting and,
you know, he was looking for a replacement,
and this guy started thinking, "Hmm, that
sounds good." And he wound up applying for
the job and got it, and now, he lives there.
And this lighthouse, when you look--I mean,
this is a lived-in lighthouse, but they use--they
have a lot of old Victorian furnishings and
things like that that they--that it's furnished
with, so it has the feeling of a kind of an
old Victorian house. But they actually live
in the place which I think is interesting.
I'm trying to think if I've seen that anywhere
else before, and I'm not sure I have. It's
unusual to see them living in it. And also
up there, they have these Marine Mammal Center,
which we have over in Stinson, you know, Rodeo
Beach, that area. We have a grand one that's
just opened. I haven't seen it yet, but I
hear it's really, you know, nice. They just
opened it a couple of months ago. This one
has been around for a while. And the Northcoast
is depressed enough even before this economic
turn down that I don't think they're going
to get a new one anytime soon but it does
the job. And these little guys come in there,
you know, and they have facilities to help
them and get them rehabilitated and then release
them again. You as a visitor are able to go
in and actually see them during the visiting
hours. They have specific hours that are open.
But if you're there when they are not open,
you can see that this kind of fences that
they have, you can see through the fences.
So you can actually see in here the animals
when nobody is there, when you can't get in.
So, it's a pleasant place to go visit. Although,
I felt sorry for these guys, you know, that
they're stuck there and were injured or whatever,
but they're helping them. Also, up in that
area, you've got the Redwood National Park,
which just goes all the way, you know, south
of Eureka and north of Eureka up to Crescent
City, it's just a lot big stretched out park,
and there's all kinds of sections to it. And
one of the things that is worth seeking out
to see when you're up there is the Roosevelt
Elk, which are--there's quite a herd of them
up there. And you can pretty much see them
in certain places that they tend to gather.
But when you're up there in that area, your
radio will bring in the transmission from
the park to tell you where they are and to
suggest where you might go to see them. So,
you can actually find out more about that
when you're on the site. And, also, I want
to mention in case you have not been up that
way, when you go up to Eureka, which is kind
of north of the Avenue of the Giants. The
Avenue of the Giants is the area where all
those huge redwoods are, you know, where--they're
just gigantic, and you see them on the side
of the road. So you want to make sure you
drive that Avenue of the Giants, you have
to get off of Highway 1, and--I think it's
around Phillips Village where you turn off,
and you just keep going on up. Just go till
it ends and then comeback to Highway 101.
The Avenue of the Giants is the old Highway
101. Years ago, that was the Highway 101.
Everybody going up that way had to go through
that. It's kind of interesting when you see
it now because you can't imagine how anybody
could drive at any kind of speed through there
and you couldn't. And--but now I have gone
there, I'd say, at least six times, you know,
in maybe the last 12 years or so. Every time
I've driven that--and it hasn't been in the
heat of summer, but it has been at other times--I
hardly ever run into anybody on that road.
It's like there's nobody there, and I kind
of wonder what's going on. More people aren't
driving along there, but it's very quite.
You can take lovely walks in the forest. And
there's all kinds of interesting things along
the way too, you know, like some stump that
supposed to be the largest stump in the world,
that kind of stuff. Some of this I put on
my book and some of it I don't because it's
really hard to document it. But as you go
along, you'll see all this stuff, and it's
really interesting. And they have little coffee
shops and things like that. Again, this is
a place that's back in time--no Ritz-Carlton's
here--and a few little places, a few little
lodgings. It's fun, really good trip. Okay,
back to Crescent Beach—-Crescent City, this
is the Crescent Beach Motel, and this is a
great one to keep in mind when you're up there
because all of the rooms are--it's a strip
motel again--and all the rooms face the ocean
there. You're facing a beach, no road in front
just the grass that you see on the little
bluff there and just down a little bit to
the beach, it's pretty flat. And, it's not
a swimming beach, you want to be careful anywhere
in the North Coast, be careful about swimming
without—-you want to know that it's safe.
And this one, I don't think they have many
safe places to swim in Crescent City. It's
also cold, you know, cold and foggy, which
we're used to. And they also have tsunamis
there. It's one of the few places where you're
going to stay in a hotel and have a tsunami
warning card, you know, "What to do incase
of a tsunami?" So--and they have--have them
there in the past so, it's a serious issue,
but usually, of course, there's some kind
of warning with that. So, if you know it's
stormy and stuff, you might want to think
about that. But then a lot of people like
to go up here for the storms. They're specifically
like to go up in the winter to watch the storms,
not a tsunami but a storm. Anyway, this is
again an inexpensive motel. As I recall, they
included breakfast which was instant oatmeal
or something like that. It was just, you know,
really next to nothing but enough to get you
started and on the road without having to
go to a coffee shop--and they did have coffee.
This is what the front looks like. Lots—-as
I said it's a stormy area, and so they have
a lot of debris that's left from that. Should
we do this?
>> You can do it quickly, yes.
>> MEYERS: Quickly, okay. And then will stop
with this. I think I'm going to show you one
winery and then will stop. Okay, we're going
to do this quick. You probably know about
a lot of them already anyway. Dim sum breakfast,
anywhere—-they serve it at the New Asia.
I like it because it's such a huge room, and
I think that adds to the experience. By the
way, if you go to my website where my travel
articles are, all of this has a hot link to
these various places. Drive down Lombard Street
a must, and especially when you got visitors
in town and you probably know that you can
go along the top there and sort of sneak in
and go down as you merge in with the tourists
who have gone up Lombard the other way. If
you've never seen the interior of a Victorian,
this is the Haas-Lilienthal house. They do
tours. It's a mansion that was here before
the earthquake and survived the earthquake
and fire and a fabulous place to visit. Another
great one to take out-of-towners to see, it's
off of Franklin Street. And virtual bowling
at the Metreon, I hope it's still there. The
Metreon has so many problems, you saw it recently.
A lot of fun because you're doing that bowling
ball down the street of San Francisco and
trying to avoid hitting the cable cars and
stuff, it's fun. We have a fabulous collection
of floating museums in San Francisco, these
old ships and boats and various things. And
then we have--the Pampanito is one of them.
And this submarine has a tour that is narrated
by a man who actually served on that submarine
during the war, and he tells the story with
it. It's very interesting. Japanese Tea Garden
always great, anytime of weather, any time
of year, any kind of weather. I loved to have
tea there.
I think that's part of the deal. But just
walking through the garden, just one of those
wonderful things that make San Francisco so
special, and getting more expensive all the
time unfortunately but still reasonable. Driving
across the Golden Gate Bridge again, you know,
the out-of-towners go nuts when you do something
like this with them. What should try to do
is take these whole lists, do everything,
blow them away and send them home, and they'll
go come back next year and you can do it again.
Slurping noodles at Mifune, which is—-I
like that little restaurant in Japan Center,
I think because it's so reliable. They have
been around forever, and they make all kinds
of noodles. They make, you know, they put
all kinds of toppings on them. There's other
places too, but this one is good. And they
have something for kids called the bullet
train, which I thought was kind of
a nice little addition to the menu. And you
get to slurp here because this is okay. In
Japan, they slurp their noodles. You can get
free walking tours with city guides, which
I believe is part of the library, the San
Francisco Library. They do tours--a walking
tour is all over the city, and they're all
free. So you can go to their website and see
what's coming up. I think they do almost every
tour at least once a month and some more frequently,
and this just is kind of fun. If you're star
struck a little bit, you might see some celebrities
at the Tosca Café in North Beach. And this
is apparently their famous drink, the brandy-laced
Ghirardelli hot chocolate. But, remember that
the celebrities apparently hang out in the
backroom, so that's what you want to watch,
see what's going on there. I've only been
there once, I didn't see anybody. But
I hear about it all the time, I just missed
this person or that person. Now, I'm going
to tell you about this and then I'm going
to stop because this is so special in the
wine country. This is new. It's a castle winery,
the Castello di Amorosa, just opened within
the last couple of years. It's an authentic
castle, brand new, built from the ground up,
not brought over from Europe but made here
with materials that some of them were brought
over from Europe. And this is Dario Sattui
who is behind it. You can go there and take
a tour and see these fabulous rooms. They
have a dungeon. They have all the things that
a castle should have, a moat. And you can
then go tasting in their vault room down below,
which is--it looks something like this, it's
not
there but that's where they store the wines.
Okay, there's a sample of
a pass that you
can get at the website. Now, I'm not sure
how to go back to my first slide, so I'll
stop there. But do we have time for questions
or...?
>> You know, I think we're going to cut the
YouTube tape just to make sure we have that
all wrapped up.
>> MEYERS: Okay.
>> But we'll be taking questions afterwards.
Again, you all can get your books in. Thank
you for joining us and welcome again.
>> MEYERS: Okay, thank you for coming. I enjoyed
chatting with you. Get out there and have
a good trip.